[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we have
with us chad miyate in the hot seat
you know what happens for hot tea right
it gets extremely toasty but it starts
very cold we ask you increasingly warm
questions by the end you're going to be
extremely uncomfortable and you won't
want to answer any of them but for now
we're going to keep it safe bart's going
to start off with a very cold question
super cold
when it comes to your fabrics fabrics
are you more of a uh iron type of guy or
a steamer
hmm
that's a good one
i normally steam i hold a shark steamer
what do you have against irons
nothing i use it for my suits steam for
regular clothes
[Music]
let's go
how did you meet
everybody here
oh that's a good question i forgot
[Laughter]
what he knows over a long ass time like
man i don't know
do you at least remember you know the
old the oldest longest year august
oh
because like we we did like videos even
before
australia didn't we i thought that he
was on the base that was shot at
we shot at a base
right the military base oh
do you remember qatar
no here illegally it was it was awesome
i can't remember when i just remember
shooting with you guys and we shot like
like a g6 and you guys were dancing and
freestyling and you had guns with nate
nate
when was damn wait how did you get up
get joined that one he was important
audience yeah bro remember we wanted
periodics for the finale
oh [ __ ] pull it up okay yeah that's
crazy okay this is one of these moments
yeah
did you know you're on a basis illegally
that was illegally yes
a lot of us could have gotten mad
trouble we broke into a military base to
do that oh
hey things that happened when you when
they broke into it
illegally yeah none of us were trying to
get away i thought it was like what did
you break today bring my old boss on
next time and then you guys can ask them
about it
we got let in by a special key
oh allegedly allegedly he just did this
hey what's there
60 people watching this video
so you've noticed that video's got to be
over 10 years old oh yeah so that's at
least 10 years that was the uncle days
yeah so you were just you were a
background dancer while they were like
doing [ __ ] or what yes okay
because poor artists are always
background dancers never to front of
stage
no we were on the [ __ ] tick tick tour
that's sure then we brought them on our
tour yeah oh no
oh it was periodic's tour yeah
yeah tic tac toy on their second floor
on their second australia tour yeah is
that the tour that was a hot disaster
no the one after that okay because
there's like our tour was dope we got
paid too because people every influencer
talks about that australian tour that
was terrible it was after us after us
okay thank god that's why they got
blacklisted and it was a different crew
that did it before they got blacklisted
yes
that other joy that went bad you guys
had nothing to do that one no we got all
the toys that were dope there you go
they tried to copy the tick tick tour it
was a competitor or something so the
same it wasn't the same crew that
brought us out some other crew brought
out tim and all these other people and
they didn't pay them because you know
youtubers back then they didn't [ __ ]
do contracts they didn't do [ __ ] none
of that [ __ ] they didn't we were the
only ones that asked for half payment up
front first right right smart yeah
because we're like
you gotta pay for the tickets but you
gotta give us some spending money bro
you know because of that disaster that's
the reason why i never did a show in
australia
because it's just scary huh well there
was two other shows after that that i
was asked to be on same thing happened
and i was like wow dodge the bullet
because that was like the accent
australian ladies is god damn beautiful
and they're [ __ ] so fun yes and they
love our accent why am i talking like
this well you guys have an accent to
them though that's why you guys are
exotic love it we are exotic there's not
it's a [ __ ] great combination yes
anyways i digress
who can you smash in a battle
all of them let's
go no but i'm going to say that out of
confidence yeah but no don't say that
yes no
wait out of honesty
yeah stop being a chat is this your
first time on jk news first time okay so
uh
if you were to explain this to joe aka
your wife
jolene uh how would you explain what jk
news is no how would you explain who joe
is
we love each other let's go
don't bring it over here we know each
other she knows me you know julian hell
yeah yeah before you guys
oh what you got to say like that man i
don't know
no no no no no no
that's a nice compliment i hope
somewhere out there someone's going hell
yeah i know ryan
it's so aggressive
[ __ ] ryan
someone knows me that hard
that hard
wait so is me
yeah is me and bart the first people
you've met or if you've met someone here
before us
we met i don't know when though actually
i mean like i met you guys on abdc so
it's like we did so we didn't know you
before you guys were on abc [ __ ] you
know i met you before abdc yeah yeah
because like when i was on pacmodern
yeah i met you when you were downtown
pack yeah yeah wow
you guys because because eris made out
with my wife at the time so what what
i love your ears we're just kidding yeah
wait but you guys weren't dating no
no we weren't dating we weren't dating
this is before i was even you phrased it
very weird no
that was my wife this is where you guys
get into a fist fight
that's so aries huh not surprised either
well eris was making out with a lot of
people exactly that's right it doesn't
count oh my god
who's heiress he's on quest
and he would always make out with girls
on dance teams yeah and he likes making
out with a lot of women yeah sure and
before i name eris dude yeah i want to
trust him from the ghetto letter dude
he's like what's your name my name is
get the [ __ ] out of my face yeah
you're sexy he sounds like a cologne
already what are you an heiress too you
[ __ ]
yeah
where are you dude what do you owe what
laughs i like that question though how
would you explain to your wife jk news
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] love jk news you know
what's funny i was listening to jk news
when i moved to china for a year for
kinjas
because like they sent me overseas to
what for hot blood dancing no it wasn't
that actually so as as you were
representing ken just in china doing
work for kinjaz yes i see uh no
kind of sort of in a more professional
way we have a partnership with a company
in china called sino stage and then they
needed a media person and chad was the
best guy so in order to get somebody
over there that both represented both
entities kenz and simon stage he was
literally not only the only but the best
representation and we asked him fairly
it's like hey true this is like a 10
month plus job and i remember asking him
that and i was like if you go
you're gonna go for like a year and he
was like i'm down so i was like that
well you were in china so he was doing
media for our sister company silent
stage it wasn't you are going for kenja
you basically did what i just did yeah
you got to get the semantics straight
you speak a little cantonese or mandarin
oh a little bit oh
did you learn
wow that's pretty good that was horrible
i'm sorry did you learn that there yes i
learned that that was my go-to saying
like i'm sorry my chinese is really bad
hey why don't you speak a little [ __ ]
cantonese you ching chong i could only
say uh my middle name and then bart was
like that's not even that good otherwise
they don't like that hey rule
that would be the worst form of whatever
you could say but continue i that's the
crazy thing is that
i can't even say anything in [ __ ]
mandarin say anything in spanish
pasadena
[Laughter]
you know what that means it means like
chinese chinese japanese you can't see
me eat [ __ ] that's what kids used to
sing yeah they used to say that [ __ ] to
me at school too but it sounds so
beautiful
let's get straight to it uh if you had
to kick somebody out of poriads who
would it be
myself
you're so safe this is a horrible one
because i was the last edition
i was i was a substitute for like wow
so there was the original five and then
they had a sixth person from san diego
who was like the
lost periodics not to be named because
he was just like a random guy
name him his name is robert robert
you're cool but then he's from san diego
so then he was never around and then jet
li went to korea to just be korean
because he loved korean girls and then
he does that thing there that's why he
went
[ __ ] i love you hey hot seat baby i
ain't lying
best hot seat
baby giving the truth out okay so then
it was like so then i was on this dance
i was on this pack modern long beach
collegiate dance team with like the
other half of periodics and they're like
we need a substitute and then they
brought me on for like these like little
gigs and we started winning first place
at all of them
and then they brought me on to this like
olympic thing or like or hip-hop
international where it's like usa versus
the world and then we won and you're
like all right you could stay i was like
sick and then from there that's how
america's best dance who recruited us
wow so you're not the worst member
you're actually the reason why they call
me the lucky charm even though i'm the
worst dancer you really feel like you're
the worst dancer i was the worst i was
only dancing for two years at that time
oh the most likely experience in general
in this capacity is very uh
subjective in the explanation i think
there's also like chad was one of the
best people to memorize counts formation
be on time you know what i mean
a whole different caliber of what it
makes to be a professional dancer
dancing well as a physicality is
different from being a professional
dancer i think chad's very professional
i agree as a dancer i like to say that
i'm a really good dancer
but i don't have those i pull up like a
g6 i don't know those those those i
can't work in a group i'm more of a
superstar but i want to ask a kenja
question
if he sucked as a dancer so hard why did
you choose to bring him in your crew
cause kingdoms is more about great
people
i don't want to be a part of it
that was literally the greatest thing
you've ever said about cancer thank you
thank you but uh but but when did that
conversation come into play because
you're part of periodics right yes and
then this is the part of i'm very
against in the dance community
the switching sides the hood hopping the
the orgy of dance members and different
crews disgusts him oh like i just [ __ ]
squad it's just loyalty right it happens
in the dance world it's a [ __ ]
disease but it's a [ __ ] disease the
olympics are horrible he's so passionate
all-star team is horrible and it's
horrible but also games are horrible
today's video is brought to you by
audible
you know what i've been listening to
uh audiobook wise oh yeah yeah i've been
listening to scars and stripes
so it's written by my good friend tim
kennedy
and he's actually really nice he told me
that um
i'm his favorite second favorite asian
on this planet oh so who's this first so
this is cool this is actually a he hatch
he actually has an adopted asian
brother talks about but anyways what's
really cool is he came out with a book
called scars and stripes and is about
like his upbringing
and um he sent me the book and i could
read it
but actually listening to it was way
better because i hear the entire story
in his voice oh so he's reading it yeah
it's his voice you can hear his emotions
so there's like so much more to the book
now than versus just
reading it in text and what i'm
imagining what he's going through you
know so it's super cool and that's why i
actually really enjoy audiobooks like in
addition to
how convenient it is and you know my
drives from vegas or whatever i can
pound through a bunch of books but also
being able to hear it from the author's
perspective is super cool that's true
and if you're a audio learner such as i
i do have a lot of books but it's much
more harder for me to actually dedicate
the time to sit there and read and make
notes and do all that stuff so when
you're on the go and you want all this
other stuff to like so when you're on
the go and you want all of these books
that you want to catch up on or whatever
it is audible is the awesome place to do
that and aside from books they have a
lot of other things too they have
entertainment they have audible
originals they have many many things
outside of just books so let audible
help you discover new ways to laugh be
inspired or be entertained new members
can try it free for 30 days visit
audible.com off the record or text off
the record to 500 500 that's audible.com
off the record to try audible for free
for 30 days audible.com off the record
because you guys are my friend i am very
accepting of diverse views and so
when did this conversation happen when
you're like you're on poor alex but you
know what like i might hop decide and i
might [ __ ] play both fields to be a
kenja and and and how like why you have
so many members already why did you
bring this guy in
why you look at me he's in a hot seat
why'd you bring him in
i just want to know how that
conversation started
i mean because i'm against it
yeah was there a yeah is there an origin
story your history with kenji's i mean
it was actually it's honestly not that
crazy i mean it started in australia
during tictic tour 2 where like became
friends
yeah we were actually really good
friends after that because that was
worse so he sucks now
no but he's still great he's actually
better now going better now yeah what
was wrong with him we get through this
story in like 15 seconds so we can move
on to juicing okay at the end of the day
everybody needs to recognize that also
me and chad were dancing on another crew
a non-profit called cold shock los
angeles together for many years
nonprofit it's different you can go to
your high school and still be a part of
boys and girls club free hood i get it
so chad myself and la duvera were
dancing together constantly and we would
do [ __ ] in our own way all the time so
because we were dancing together it was
kind of like regardless of crews it was
like yo we already rocked together
kendricks was never like a one team or
nothing it was always like you you give
what you want from it and like blah blah
blah that's it he doesn't like it cool
let's move on he's skeptical look at joe
right now dude you're able to move like
anthony very well yeah he's one of the
greatest movers that i [ __ ] know it's
not just my style but in general make
money
have you ever have you ever been doing a
dance that he taught
and you were like
i don't really like it but i have to do
it anyway
you're like he just does too much
[ __ ] iso [ __ ] obviously the answer is
yes honestly i'm already team isil i
came from a team that's all [ __ ]
robotics and [ __ ] but what about all the
emotional song choices he likes this
[ __ ] i'm a scorpio so we're naturally
freaked out
emotional so i was like i vibed with
everything anthony was doing chad's a
good boy huh
thank you hawk thank you me too foul
dude no i mean
means everything this means headlines
and this means it was made to tour tick
tick toy
so many friendships memories and [ __ ]
things happened from that tour and
they're still there i'm still friends
with everybody there
victor's on skinny
oh [ __ ] bald joe
joe you look like you just got out of
prison dude
i'm kidding
dude you look racist yeah
white people
it's american history [ __ ] is this you
know what the funniest thing is so there
was like this uh music video that uh is
that can
uh yeah so yeah i literally thought uh
dumbo was a girl for the longest time
and i remember i talked to jeff that guy
on the left i was like it's really
progressive that you guys have of one
female member
jet started cracking the [ __ ] up no
you're not bullshitting me you swear to
god i legit thought he was a girl
so like and it was really interesting
because he was wearing a tank top i was
like yo let's go kind of free dude
so i was tripping the [ __ ] out this girl
kind of freaked out
no girl definitely not a girl this is
not a joke i legit and then
you know i think it's his wife now right
they were making out on set and i was
like dude had a lesbian
this [ __ ] kind of hot
and i was like yo this is hot as [ __ ]
yeah and then my mind went and then he
jacked up the dumbo that night yeah dude
yeah
i was legit shocked that was one of the
most embarrassing moments for me ever
when i'm literally talking to somebody
that's his close friend and i'm like
dude man really progressive man you guys
have one female member and he starts
busting up laughing and he's was like i
already know who you're talking about i
was like what do you mean i didn't get
what he was laughing about i was like
what are you talking about i'm like holy
[ __ ] that tank top skinny girl he's a
boy
i love how it's not even just pictures
of videos it's like you're still seeing
them in real life and making that
assumption
this is a bold skinny girl
good for you yeah well it wasn't this
one it was a tour before where
cannes dick story happened
yeah his
kickstarter
the big black chocolate cake more
context to that which is probably why he
got more embarrassed from that love you
can is because like we were at a club
and we were judging a bunch of like go
go dancer girls
that were dressed it was like towards
halloween wearing like nurse outfits and
like
they were just like a bunch of hot girls
and they were just like walking down a
catwalk we're all judging them and then
like that's when the cake came out and
then we saying happy birthday can so
it's more embarrassing in front of the
girl
a hundred percent wait what happened he
nodded he jumped his face in the cake
and now now he hates chocolate forever
yeah
wait really
for real because of that
[ __ ] oh
yeah because he was on like mushrooms or
something so he had a massive bad trip
wow can't get over it chocolate's great
don't demonize chocolate the positive
the positive part though is black dicks
are perfectly fine
because the shape of a black dick cake
is completely fine no bias toward that
but chocolate
okay
because it's pushed into chocolate cake
there's a chocolate dick cake chocolate
and he doesn't like chocolate because of
that because of that yeah he got but now
he likes dick
yes
[Laughter]
i used to love chocolate i hated dick
but now
so on cam's embarrassing moment right
have you ever had anything like that
like that you're just like oh god this
is crazy and i just can't get over it
cause you're on the hot seat we gotta
let we gotta know yes yeah it's gotta be
on yeah yeah we know about cans
this has been the best diversion of hot
seat from the gas though yeah
it's been about everybody else except
the kids i know we haven't heard much of
your stuff hey welcome to me i know he's
really good at that because i observe
what's the worst thing that happened
within periodics worst thing that
happened within the team yeah within the
team i just like the way he said
periodic
takes i never heard it like that before
are you trying to [ __ ] after this
bro let's go dude
it's too sexy yeah
i mean other than like
the group semi
breaking up into
not semi breaking up like couple members
that had to leave and then us picking up
new members and like figuring it out and
becoming like and keep going
and yeah so what's that what's that
experience like right because there's a
certain chemistry when you have a
certain group and you're trying to bring
other people in how do you work that
i mean at least like when we were
picking up other people we were trying
to pick up people that we were dancing
with on like other teams or like that we
knew beforehand or that were cool guys
that could possibly even move like us or
that would vibe with the squad
so that's what we did like we picked the
people that we knew
and then speaking of which hot take hot
take hot tea when you guys were voting
on me how did you vote well yeah because
because like you were about to join you
were supposed to be on friday if you
didn't know anthony performed a few
times with periodics a few times
you're like [ __ ] four feet taller
than everybody in the group that's
that's one of the main reasons why he
didn't make it on the spot you would
stand out john
that's true everybody was four feet tall
and anthony was seven foot houses look
the same
stew
what do you think is that
the same touch
that's true
we're out here
[Music]
yeah it's funny because like when we
were in rehearsal over anthony like i
said everyone was like four foot tall so
then i was like right anthony
you gotta get
you gotta squat yeah take a seat anthony
yeah but i love you was that one of the
main reasons why he didn't make the cut
to pour y'all that was one of the main
revenge story where you said well [ __ ]
you then i'm going to be a king john
[ __ ] you get smaller
so yeah that was one of the main things
i was like we were all rehearsing at
quest dance center which is where these
are from where they know the trademark
that was very disloyal by the way you
didn't have your own dance group
you might as well go all the way i know
right me or anthony i mean why would you
practice at the quest center when you
were poreiatic like because we didn't
because we didn't have a periodic center
well you had my living room
that's what he's bitter about
do you want us to practice hey just
answer the question what was your vote
yeah oh my vote was hell yeah anthony
should be it and then i got vaped wait
wait go back other other
let's go back let's go back real quick
and finish up that story because i want
to know what i've been you're about to
vote for you to be on jk news for
years to ask this question
i am yeah i'll tell you this i remember
um so i was in i think i was in italy
with charles yes i was in italy charles
we had performed a few times charles was
uh lobbying for me to join the crew
because it was like kind of like a
disconcerting time your guys management
had [ __ ] you all over again again
there was like a lot of [ __ ] blah blah
but i had enjoyed dancing with half
y'all post tick tick because like it was
all cool
so that's why you were recruiting now i
remember i remember i was like uh we
gotta we got a dtr we gotta define the
relationship so they had a whole
conversation about me right and i
remember it was la de vera who's also
king just love you love
he was the one who broke the news and he
pretty much said that like yo
uh a lot of [ __ ] has happened to
periodics and right now instead of
bringing in new people finding out
something new
we gotta rework everything that had
happened and find ourselves before we
can add somebody else yep which is true
and i was like that's very respectable
so then after i was like cool and not
preaching then i was like let me go full
force with kendra's and then bring
charles over to you guys and chad and
chad and law yeah
dan you're a genius
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you shall not pause
so did just tell us this did any of the
people that voted against him end up in
king's
no
there's your answer oh
i never made that call consciously
and it's never fully up to me
it's never fully okay but you felt it
you want the truth of kendra's i never
make a decision about myself on who
joins the crew i can never do that it's
never allowed sorry dumbo
[Laughter]
yeah that's what you get for wearing
tank tops and seducing me
you